got a news flash for you bozos the card
game is back on sale oh my God the
original edition of the card game some
of our favorite questions right here got
about 50 or so of them sold a bunch of
them put them on the shelf for a little
while now we're doing one final run of
the original series one last job baby
it's a good good time to get hammered
with your friends and find out at the
people that you know and that you love
are garbage so do yourself a favor the
link is in the description pick up a
pack today because they're gonna go
quick oh yeah and that ain't it tubby we
got Road dates baby we got two shows in
Atlanta coming up in November then we're
going to Charlotte North Carolina if
you're in the area get those tickets for
that we got two in Philly that are sold
out we got one left in Providence Rhode
Island those tickies are moving we got
one left in Boston that is for sure
gonna sell out get those tickets we won
a party see you there here welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out the
girl to be classy yeah to just a big old
piece of trash yeah that's right I'm
your hostage yeah that's right garbage
trash coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antody's basement
she's upstairs bad case of mesothelioma
as soon as she can find a lawyer that'll
play ball and a doc I watch a little
daytime yeah she's been up late huh
because either that or she was a marine
at Camp Lejeune in 1965. they're going
Heavy after you drink gasoline yourself
to whatever was in that water was no
voice the core never hurt nobody what
the hell
my Carlos is coming at you they're
trained killers
hahaha
my cows is coming at you from across the
table this is a family episode he is the
CEO of are you garbage and the pumping
picking champion of 2013. give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan
because it's the fall baby thanks for
tuning in everybody
uh make sure you please rate review
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
true to roof oh my God yikes swing and a
miss by a new guy Luke ladies and
gentlemen uh then obviously I'd be
remiss I'd be a jerk off of being
[ __ ] I'd be distraction
um
if I didn't mention the greatest goddamn
website of all [ __ ] I ain't
talking Google I ain't talking ask jeez
I ain't talking
xxnxvideos.net which ain't bad it's all
right that's a close number two you know
what was big back in the day early on
before
you didn't know what you were doing to
ruin a [ __ ] Gateway real quick
dude you're ruining a Dell oh man jammed
up with freeones.com
you could that was like the first time
you could search by hey who who's my
favorite star H Foley you could type in
that click the name and then all the
stuff would come up Hachi you like
little little wieners huh
gang how about a nice question on
patreon.com
I forgot we got a whole bunch of stuff
on there we're gonna get XNXX online I
apologize we're closing in on our next
goal uh which is when we hit it we will
do uh buying a storage unit yeah we're
gonna go to an auction do Storage Wars
hopefully [ __ ] get rich quick schemes
that's what I'm gonna take those
hillbillies for a ride uh we just did uh
we just one of the bonus we do weekly
bonuses ayg weekly uh hard feelings one
of the bonus we just it was on a road in
the car in Missouri out there was a good
old time check it out good good good
good time and gang listen what our good
pal T-Bone with McMuffin is that with
the sniffies yeah he's Sicky Wiki so we
got new guy Luke filling in he's a young
good-looking his hands are shaking it
looks like he's never touched a computer
I don't know what's going on he's taking
the SATs over there Gang new guy Luke
ladies and gentlemen
how are we doing guys oh man he is he is
a behind the scenes kind of guy T-Bone
your job is safe tell you that right now
[ __ ] NPR Paul over here let the
lights go off real quick
buddy thank you for filling in we
appreciate it T-Bone feel better we love
you uh we just got jammed up to a
recording schedule he's sick we got to
get these episodes done that's the way
it works you know what I mean yeah is
that the family business okay all right
you know it's just very like right
you're looking at me like go along with
this
long hair
body we love you feel better
what are you doing
it's fine we
answer he's fine well I love you
exactly he's in a hospital bed or
something he's fine had a little bit of
a scary incident yesterday oh God that's
never good I was down in The Burbs we're
driving from one place to another and I
find a
you all right I just let him do his job
man you're freaking out oh man he's
looking around like he's [ __ ] out in
left field with a hockey stick that's my
line yes it's great I think I stole from
my cousin
um
I just looked over he's checking to make
sure the cameras are on Daddy was
looking at the boxes no
um
spider the big man doesn't like changes
so this is this is a big curveball in
your in your mix hey I love new guy Luke
I know but I don't think in the back
seat of a minivan he's saying nothing I
don't think you like them on the ones
and twos that makes doing the beeps and
the sweets yeah I don't want this guy
feeding the M60 when I'm in the [ __ ]
Fox song I want a T-bone in there Johnny
on the [ __ ] spot that's right
um we love you buddy T-Bone hope you
feel better my friend stop doing that
she's gonna be Services later
in lieu of flowers flowers please we
send gift cards send some grip tape to
uh Teddy's basement
um driving in the car uh-huh
um I got my nephew with me okay he's in
the passenger seat sitting up front and
I hear him go wow look at that spider
that's the biggest spider I've ever seen
thinks it's on the outside of the window
it ain't [ __ ] in the car yeah
I'm talking the size of a Sacagawea like
heavy bike this thing had a piece on it
I'm telling you right now what'd you do
because you're not one to kill spiders
well I am I'll kill anything if it moves
I shoot well I ask questions later I
almost I almost killed the three of us
save the spider you're going off a cliff
dude I was trying to shake him off like
he was Jackie Chan I'm telling you right
now we both freaked out because when we
realized it was inside you're not a cool
cucumber either no you lose it quick and
I don't like I don't like chaos in the
car when I'm driving so he starts but
you mainly cause by the way he starts
freaking out it's on me oh my God
screaming and this thing like that and
then all right those foleys are cool
under pressure
main headquarters of the Bureau of crazy
yeah
spider disappears for a minute he thinks
it it went out the window it didn't it
was they never do it was on me
it was it was on my hair now he's
driving the bus
so he's freaking out he takes off his
shoe you keep making the stops there's
people kept ringing the bell he's
hitting me with his flip-flop oh my God
you guys are idiots and now every last
one of you and we never got him we
pulled over we searched the entire car I
can't find this thing yeah I know he's
not dead it's just like home alone with
with Buzz's tarantula dude I'm roaming
around I he thinks he got him a little
bit when he got him he hits crawling
down here
Henry don't move
what are you doing
what are you doing kid what are you
doing I'm never getting in that goddamn
car again dude I'm telling you if it was
just a regular fighting setup it was
just a regular Spider I'd be okay this
thing means business I feel like they'd
be getting bigger and Bolder too a
little bit Yeah remember we had one on
our window in [ __ ] Missouri or
wherever the [ __ ] we were we were doing
like a buck 80 down I i-72 and this
thing was like just [ __ ] chilling on
the outside of the window smoking a
burning out in a heater so he thinks he
got it when it was on the headrest but
it wasn't where it would it should have
fallen so he's injured he's in the car
and he's probably upset with us yeah so
good luck I'm an Uber man I don't know
what to tell you dude I drove up from
Philly this morning man I was the whole
way just petrified just waiting for this
[ __ ] to make a move I was waiting to
feel the the the cold metal on my throat
your hand on your piece yeah
everything's fine just waiting it's
trying to set a trap for him to come out
take out the engine block I mean yeah
point the only thing to do is put my
seatbelt on if I can do a quick jerk
Herky jerky put a mouthpiece in and
crash into a wall
to pull pull a payback on it it's a deep
cut shout out to Mel Gibson ah
yeah so that's how uh that's how my day
yesterday my morning went that's pretty
good yeah I got one for you I was just
uh I just got back from uh Europa are
you uh jet lagged uh Kai was up at five
o'clock this morning which ain't good
okay you know uh it's easier on the way
back every thoughts changed as your
opinion changed on the uh what the
Russia Ukraine situation did they turn
you over there I don't know I was I was
digging around snooping around a
pipeline I don't know if you heard you
got all your fingernails that's a good
sign I'm missing that dude
um how do you feel about the call button
on a plane will you call the attendant
over if I'm on fire maybe yeah no never
really and you know I wanted to talk to
you about this which I've never said it
but oh God every once in a while we'll
be on the plane and you'll hear it yeah
what is that that that's the engine
shutting off
so I've got some switching over to
[ __ ] hyperdrive somebody left the
trunk open uh what is that yeah usually
it's that or some sort of service call
so you hear it throughout the whole
plane uh that might be like I think they
also communicate them set like the they
have their own language the I don't like
that the uh the the air to talk to the
front and the back yeah the air skanks
[Laughter]
that was rude this ain't hard feelings
sorry this is a public program jeez
um no uh
yeah my wife was using it using it quite
a bit what do you mean what do you need
it's a long flight eight and a half
hours I get my business class by the way
I really Machi I am broke that's
patreon.com that's German business too
what do you mean yeah I had to go over
and secure more funding more [ __ ]
hemorrhaging cash over here what do you
think pays new guy who spills what the
[ __ ] sit down with Swiss back yeah I had
a [ __ ] yeah I had to sit down with
[ __ ] half of the half of the EU they
said no bueno I got a couple gold bars
with a Balinese dancer on it
oh man well payback for the Boston Tea
Party huh playing Hardball fly back
economy yeah it's a deal the Queen's
dead who's got the cash
um yeah I'm like I I this was a big
thing because I'm a big no [ __ ] no I
don't want that but I feel like you're
paying they they that's the sir and what
do you mean this was her argument right
if you said economy at any point if you
want to get up and get a couple like on
those long flights we're flying
Lufthansa you're allowed to uh they have
like a snack bar type thing where you
get up and they have like Waters poured
they have like a tray of water waiting
for you a call you can go you can get up
and go get stuff a buffet it's okay
that's how fast we are you here a cup of
water and you go Buffet wait you could
just go get it yourself because I see
blue does that everybody kind of has
that you can get up and walk back and go
like hey you know can I have a cup of
coffee or a tea or whatever huh when
they're back there like they're catching
heaters and stuff I know [ __ ] playing
Tiddly wings I assume they're fooling
around man nothing like an attractive
flight attendance dude even the guy
anybody if you're if you're just on a
plane and you're not a hundred I'm into
it that's my cup of tea yeah
um but
they don't have that for the uh business
class because they want to give us they
want to you know they don't want you
getting up they have German Shepherds
patrolling the eyes
someone peed on me
Spotlight goes around the plane yeah she
was using she used it a couple of times
and at some point I'm like yo tuts
listen reel it in a little bit now
obviously she could do whatever she
wants she's the boss of course
um and don't tell her I said this but
she doesn't listen to the proof what I
don't even think she knows we have a
program what do you she thinks you're
making sweaters yeah she doesn't know
what we're doing down here
um
what do you need that you can't hey when
they walk by can I grab a they're not
always walking by though
yeah they'll just go like pop in the
back because they're not
like they'll come to the service but
then they're like just [ __ ] they're
chilling in the back reading a magazine
or whatever yeah I'm too scared to use
it I'm always afraid I'm gonna hit the
oxygen thing and now everything's gonna
fall down [ __ ]
guy goes upside down all right somehow
crash the plane yeah inverted
um speaking of that can I tell you a
scary airplane story that was told to me
this week this isn't even your story now
I could make it my story
this is Top Gun goddammit I got two migs
behind me on my tail converting them
both the finger ah sure
um buddy a buddy of mine
Went to went to uh was cut was flying
down to Costa Rica with his family
they're just about off the coast of
Florida okay smoke in the cabin yay
American Airlines flight smoke in the
cabin right freaking Spirits flight huh
laughs
welcome to Paul Mall Airlines ladies and
gentlemen yeah if I can smoke him a
peace pipe in the back catching 80s
someone's ripping a dude but the
bathroom otherwise we're in trouble
um also you know there's different
classes of bathrooms on planes found
that out what yeah what are you talking
about what do you mean where were you
all week what's going on here
you're in our future
um we gotta do we gotta do three weeks a
year in [ __ ] Frankfurt Germany just
bought a lithium mine in there North
Ghana
we're moving hoodies over there yeah
um hold on sidebar that what are you
talking about different economy has a
different bed I found this out you can
go to either one though you can't
because we got bumped out of the first
class one
yeah which is not trash yeah I didn't
know there was a I thought business was
in first class were just pseudonyms
probably in there going out like a
couple of wraps leather toilet seat
leather oh that's real German I don't
like nuts Daryl what are you talking
about would you like a ball gag while
you poop
two
ah too yeah I'm sure her whole family's
listening to this now they're just over
there too oh what's the show we'll check
it out first bag I'm just mimicking them
um what that's wild yeah I don't like
the push into the button you start you
asked them what do you need what you
need that's why I know what she need she
was drinking some sort of mango juice
really yeah it's called a mango Shola
I'm gonna pronounce that wrong it's that
it's mango with like a little bit I
guess like sparkling water like Seltzer
and maybe something else those Germans
do juices I also I don't know if you've
ever seen a German breakfast but Hachi
Machi just a bunch of cold meats and
vegetables [ __ ] stinks Shadow vodka
and a bullet yeah it's [ __ ] rough
anyway so
they're on the plane
they're just about off the coast of
Florida smoking the cabin yeah 40 000
feet they're cooking okay Captain comes
on we got an emergency everybody get
your seatbelts on get your heads down
don't say a word don't get up don't
start screaming you do any of that stuff
when we get on the ground [ __ ] don't
give you I'll give you a right hook up
turn this point around and we'll go home
he's like you do anything like that
you'll be arrested as soon as we land
dude [ __ ] drops it 40 000 feet to
like six thousand feet
kids said they were on the ground in
about eight minutes from forty thousand
feet I know but that's always hard for
me to like I mean if I can't quantify
six thousand feet to 40 000 feet yeah
you can when you're [ __ ] facing
straight down and your eyeballs are
getting sucked in the back of your head
there's no call Button there I can tell
you that yeah he thought it was it
engine was on fire
went down hit six thousand feet they
looped around landed in Miami they took
that same plane the next day to Costa
Rica they fixed it that quick you're
nuts back to Philly also you can tell
you've been hanging out with your family
too much it's all [ __ ] dread stories
every time you come back do you hear
about Mr Wilson shot in the head four
times
uh yeah it's a good time down here but
that's neither here nor there gang this
is a family episode we answer your
garbage questions when you sign up for
the patreon we will answer your garbage
questions on the air we have a little
bit of a backlog but we're working
through
uh also real quick uh I want to give a
quick shout out happy birthday to our
boy Greg Bourne shout out to Greg Bourne
okay just wanted to do that real quick
do I know Greg no I knew you're gonna
make this weird I forgot to talk to you
about it beforehand is this one of your
German contacts is that some [ __ ] KGB
signal Luke you [ __ ] believe this
pcsurian candidate Luke just looks over
Greg Bourne Luke looks over at you jumps
out of this
he started eating ramen noodles yeah I'm
calling Homeland Security that's what
Denzel ate candidate the Remake which
was pretty good
I remember watching that the first time
hungover oh my God I was in college I
didn't know what it was like I'll throw
this on it was all proper Comcast On
Demand oh my dude the Panic that said if
wondering if I was a goddamn candidate
waiting for him to flip the [ __ ]
switch on the camera yeah I didn't like
that I haven't looked at anybody the
same since by the way I didn't like that
I don't like Inception and I didn't like
uh tenant I liked the movies but there
was just too much tenant I don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on oh yeah I
started in the middle half of it's going
backwards no that's not for me [ __ ]
kooky patooky
no thank you I thought it was about a
landlord for the longest time yeah
nothing on that all right
the rent is due
so Greg Bourne yeah happy birthday shout
out to our boy Greg born that's all he's
our boy yeah he's a listener okay yeah
all right yeah I'm gonna say I don't
know this man I know yeah I also don't
personally know the man either shout out
to him ah it's good stuff yes okay let's
talk about that manscape oh baby the
best in the [ __ ] listen I know summer's
over you think about letting things go
now is the time to tighten it up a
little bit yeah all right just because
the Corn's been picked doesn't mean you
want to let the pubes grow out sure the
old saying yeah this ain't the 90s all
right we used to bang with that back in
the day they like the Muff now they
don't you got to keep it clean and you
got to keep it smelling good and
manscape you could get the old Platinum
package uh-huh which includes the
lawnmower there what else you got the
weed whacker oh my God we got the
lawnmower to do the parts down there
keep the balls clean and you got the
weed whack you could do your nose your
ear that's where you really get tripped
up especially as you get older you got
to take care of that ear hair don't
think that oh it's okay I'm older it
doesn't matter nothing more gross than
eating a pizza pizza and looking over
and your buddy's got uh blueberry trees
coming out of his ears I think that's a
personal shot of me but look yourself a
favor try to enjoy my slice uh guys they
also have the premium body wash uh Ultra
Premium 21 shampoo and conditioner your
skin and hair will be feeling hydrated
and smelling fresh for the broads out
there okay this is all trying to we're
trying to impress broads right you got
to be smelling nice so they come over
and they talk to you spit some game and
maybe you convince them you got you two
hit it off you go back to your place or
her place yeah or to his place whatever
and they go down and then they open up
the pants and it's the monster's house
yeah it's no good run a tight chip
especially in a winter no one's
expecting it so when you do go down
there and it's a and it's clean you got
your nice little V going looks like the
ninth Fairways they're gonna love it uh
guys you get 20 off in free shipping
with code garbage at manscape.com that's
20 off plus free shipping with the code
garbage at manscape.com manscaped clear
out the leaves it's your tree trunks
time to shine baby do it Kip I like that
freeze pipe cold as ice I'm telling you
right now back when I was a kid you were
doing gravity bongs you'd burn your
lungs plastic throat your smell on that
and I would freeze pipe baby lowers the
smoke about 300 degrees to get nice
thick puffy clouds and start raining in
that place really really cools it down
it's a good good time we got the bubbler
threw that in the freezer lit that up
didn't even realize it I was halfway to
Pluto I'm telling you that right now I
didn't feel the goddamn thing do
yourself a favor grab a freeze pipe you
will not regret it I promise you yeah
the good folks over there freeze Piper
nice enough to send to treat them
[ __ ] bad boys over here I walked in
it was like a Cypress Hill music video I
thought Snoop Dogg was [ __ ] behind
the buttons over there for a test ride
uh the secret is the freezable glycerin
chambers that come on every piece pop
one of those chambers in the freezer for
an hour and be ready to go smoke is
cooled instantly it passes through the
icy chamber pipes bubblers bongs dab
rigs and more handjobs hookers and
gazoos if you smoke if you can smoke it
freeze pipe makes it baby so head on
over to the freezepipe.com enjoy your
new favorite piece at everyday great
prices use garbage for 10 off your next
order that's the t-h-e freezepipe.com
and code garbage for ten percent do it
um all right let's see here this one's
from Danny t uh have you ever bought
clothes for the family photo shoot and
return them to the store after 100 for
the photo shoot oh no we never did that
that picture right behind you up there
yeah you think that Blazer stayed at the
house I mean I don't think it fits
anymore [ __ ] went right back I think all
those outfits except for my dad's
uniform all went back to the store uh
that that stuff I mean that go in a
little place to get it done that [ __ ]
phased out before I got old like yeah it
was probably like when you were a kid
they were still existing I have one with
a picture of me and my little brother
there and I remember being like this is
cuckoo bananas we're doing here I'm
holding a wiffle ball bat or something
it's real bad I know that picture oh
yeah the big fat one not the skinny
yellow one I think it's a skinny yellow
one really that's I don't know he was a
baby and I was 10. it's got electrical
tape on it yeah he's gonna [ __ ] post
it for sure Dirtbag
um
no we never did that that [ __ ] never we
just got we never got like portraits
like we would never that like we never
did that that's crazy to me yeah like we
would do like oh you're dressed up at
Easter let's get a picture at Easter
then you're right on the back like
Easter 1992 or whatever I remember the
fights that that photo caused um it was
a Wednesday he had my dad just got home
from work busting his ass all day Luke
what the [ __ ] are you doing new guy Luke
creeping around
uh what are you doing
what's that doing he's fixing the curse
just let him go I I love how is this
what you do when you do your face when
you do your big acting jobs what's this
guy looking at stop looking at me I
freak out like Christian Bale
Never Again Luke you're British all of a
sudden
um
that was a huge fight that was that was
my dad getting home from work we had to
be there you got to wear this you got to
do this my brother had hit me I had
makeup on my face it was it was a whole
it was a whole big nightmare they
weren't cool
I'll take that though over the picture
of everybody wearing white on the beach
oh man you gotta have a couple of those
no you're Beach people yeah yeah we're
poor Beach people we were poor Beach
people we were hot dogs in a cooler
people not we weren't [ __ ] white
polos and khakis on the beach at dust
all white Eagles jerseys everybody's
doing away right
are we home or away shirts and skin
instead of that Kelly Green [ __ ] all
right shout out to the birds by the way
cooking
um I uh I remember one time it's just
funny because this picture resurfaced
um when my grandfather passed away
it started making the rounds because
it's a whole fat it was their it was my
grandparents 50th anniversary wedding
anniversary big deal sure right my aunt
was uh working for the city like pretty
high up in the city or whatever so she
got it done she had the service done at
the Cathedral service or like they had
like a service like a mass or something
or like they ringed in their vowels or
something there was some sort of like
proper thing at some like at the
Cathedral in Philadelphia it's not
trashy the redoing of the vows
50 I don't think so I mean these are old
these are old bags you know
I think if you're doing it after you
cheated in Vegas yeah it's one you know
what I mean you come back when you get
caught with herpes or something yeah
next time I'm serious yeah exactly I'll
never I'll never have sex with a skeezer
again that's a little different than you
know 50 years 50 years that's a lot
um
and I'm in my like my dad's or my
brother's old sweater like Arrow if I
was dressed so poorly because I was I
could never I was I was so fat and would
get fatter by the day oh fat piece of
[ __ ] I'm sure I guess wearing your mom's
pants your dad's sweater
I am
I got her shoulder pads in
um I think I have my brother's like old
like Arrow pastel sweater I could just
never get dressed up and Danny could
because he was like you know an In-Shape
good looking kid he's a tough look he
could get he looked like the guy in the
like the mannequin yeah you're eating in
front of the choir sister let me tell
you I know exactly what you're talking
like a [ __ ] slob so I didn't have it
doesn't matter anyway if you showed up
Perfect 10 minutes in you're gonna look
like of course you look like it's like a
it's like you like the fuse when you
dress a fat guy yeah it's [ __ ] it's a
wrap it's like a three in the dryer for
a couple of minutes I know
um
but I'm wearing this is bad and like I
remember so I didn't have under white I
guess I didn't have clean underwear so I
wore like a pair of Umbro like soccer
shorts or basketball shorts as underwear
what kind of pants do you have on like
corduroy it's just something to do is
real mad he must have been swishing
hear you coming down
not to mention you probably got a little
Stinger because of all the friction
going on that's sad too that's all right
that's like wearing silk baby
you guys have a shirt you just keep
walking give me a minute walk up I mean
I'll see you guys in there hey
let's get started
what a fat little bastard
[Laughter]
um
Bros
and corduroys hey we're blue with white
stripes dude I'll never forget them man
that must have been a good time
because the corduroy's got a little
sweaty yellow Reds ripped for its
pleasure you're wearing them inside out
trying to get your freak on [ __ ]
oh God you can see this in the picture
did you no yeah you can see the string
in one of the picture because my
drawstring's hanging out and my aunt I
think it was my aunt Quinny was taking
the picture of all the grandkids and I'm
dead I'm dead that's why when my
grandfather passed all these pictures
are coming around this one has all of
the grandkids in it so like this was the
one that like whatever and my five I
have a white drawstring hanging out of
the front of my cords
am I Inc Winnie because she goes Kevin
you're strings
I think I is my underwritis
I remember being so I remember being
like oh man I'm a [ __ ] I remember
that was like a that was a turning point
it wasn't rock bottom but it was close I
didn't turn around for another about 15
years but oh God yikes that's bad
oh yeah
I am what I am what do you want from me
up there you're telling me you never
been jammed up in a bad situation I'm in
a bad situation right now
got a pair of biker shorts on kidding me
yeah I'm cooking right now no but I had
a pair of suit pants on uh this week and
you know I'm going up now I'm going over
you go over the belly I go over the
belly now
um under the balls
[Laughter]
walking the beats
sure
uh
pants go up above the belly but the
undies go normal
whoa yeah I can't oh no I'm not up so
you have no man's land in there oh yeah
wow yeah really you gotta send up a
flare to collect the bodies that's crazy
call it a ceasefire no way yeah there's
a space you're raw dogging the belly's
raw dogging in the pants yeah yeah huh
which ain't great no no and I can't
because the positioning of the zipper I
can't just pull down and pee I gotta
undo everything I always undo everything
well my belt was real heavy and the
pants were real light and when I went to
do it my pants fell down as I was peeing
and I was at a urinal not in a stall and
I was around family and friends so
people walked into the bathrooms
my pants were around my ankles and I was
peeing why don't you bend down to pick
them up I was urinating you can't
[ __ ] suck in no that's gone oh yeah
that's
that's uh you couldn't cut it off if you
had to
and we start shooting nah it'd be messy
and I get it all down there humble in
the gun like Fredo oh 100 Papa yeah
you're losing it uh okay no bueno so
don't feel bad but you're a little freak
I'll tell you that
[Music]
uh you should have just wore a pair of
your sister's underwear or something I'm
gonna do it I'll do that now I didn't I
didn't know you could go both do that
now on the weekends yeah
um all right let's see here this one's
from Nolan first time new ten dollar
homie shut up shout out to the ten
dollar homies uh have you ever parked at
a gas pump just to go into the store
that's a big you gotta you kind of gotta
do that in New York
if you're driving in New York because
there's no parking spots I do that Wawa
all the time even if I'm even if I'm not
filling up really [ __ ] them yeah cause
it's a pain in the ass getting out of
those spots especially at the super
Wawas with the gas tanks because they're
[ __ ] right there
yeah you just pull in there I don't know
it took me a while to break that I've
just started to do it because I used to
have like anxiety that if I got gas and
then went in to get a couple of things
the cars sitting there cars sitting
there yeah but they got [ __ ] nine
pumps no I know if it's Heck if it's
jammed up that's a problem
if if the pump stand if it's no yeah if
it's hectic you can't wait in line then
like pull in and just be like I'll leave
her here I'll be back come back with a
sodium yeah yeah yeah you can't do that
um there's rules we're living in the
society people I would tell you the time
the rules are breaking down everybody's
doing what they want I know but he gives
a [ __ ]
uh I locked the I locked my keys in my
car at the gas pump how do you do that
in in 2022 no this was 20 this was 2005
probably 2004. shout out to my [ __ ]
1996 Chevy you can't do that with the
Kia right if you leave your fob in the
car to let you know I don't have a fob
that's why wait what yeah I have a key a
key that's why this key a challenge
that's going around where they're
stealing like apparently Kia and Hyundai
they're getting stolen like crazy
because they like buy one day not
Hyundai
you say Hyundai I say whatever unless I
say syrup yeah whatever you say a lot of
things wrong too pillow sounds like huge
all right how many pillows you sleeping
how many times I've seen guests stare at
you like what is this what is this huge
man talking about how many pillows you
sleep with hey my size has nothing to do
with that it's ridiculous you're
smuggling some pillows I say restaurant
a lot too so you see a lot of things
proper wrong yeah
um
but
days like so they can be hijacked with
like a USB like the keyless ones like
the push to start Jones you can kind of
just like is yours push to start no I'm
turning to start analog old school so
they can't get you I mean yeah I doubt
it's you know it's probably easier than
stealing a [ __ ] man getting your car
stolen with a [ __ ] Nintendo switch
that's real [ __ ] trash my buddy had
his car stolen and like every time I got
back in it they like found it they found
it in the Bronx uh it was a nice car too
uh
every time I got in and I'm like I just
feels it's not even my car and I'm like
this feels weird can you not take it
back can you say I'm not taking this car
no the insurance company goes that
you're [ __ ] you know we've recovered
the car it's your car
[ __ ] that yeah probably homeless guys
jerking off in there yeah soup kitchen
touching their balls Dirty Mike and the
boys
um like that at all you know it's a dick
move not a dick move but it's a douche
move leaving the car running with like
if you pull up at like a 7-Eleven you
pull up in the front car running Windows
Down music on that's like look at me
look at me oh that are backing into a
spot that don't need to be backed into
kick Resort I like it back then though
it depends where it is you're backing
into the front row of the 7-Eleven
you're wrong backing into a driveway is
really nice I feel like if you're about
to rob that hash like this guy's ready
to play ball oh yeah you got it yeah
ready ready to [ __ ] truck you
headlights are always on
um
the music thing is so [ __ ] obnoxious
it's like I I probably I don't remember
I don't recall but I probably did it
when I was 16 and like thought I was
cool not even that but people in the
city they'll pull into like a fire
hydrant spot like waiting for somebody
and they'll keep the music blasting if
you have the music blasted and you're
constantly moving I'll give you that
enjoy your life but if you're sitting
still
you got to be ready to fight somebody I
that's that's crazy that's wild that
knows those things are the Whistler tips
dude I want to smash a [ __ ] rock
through one of their [ __ ] yeah you
gotta get out of the city you're getting
too old for this [ __ ] getting too old
for it we were talking about that
[ __ ] today Jersey's looking pretty
good
got a tomato Farm out there
tomato Farm eat my own crop
um all right this one's from Christian
10 down home and I read a question read
ever owned anything from copperfit
those socks the t-shirts
remember those bracelets that have like
magnetic powers and then pitchers
started wearing those [ __ ] things
yeah the necklaces yeah there's a bead
in there there yeah no yeah I guess I
think the I do like my compression socks
though well that's proven to work yeah
that's titanium it's not copper oh
there's metal in there yeah wire in
there whoa yeah
if I get jabbed to the metal detector
I think I'm Wolverine no there's no
metal in there yet you know they're just
tight socks
that go up really high
okay they leave a dent too when you get
it when you get into the hotel and I
take those babies off talking about who
Let The Dogs Out yikes that's a good
feeling peeling those things off
ah and they're probably so your leg
probably goes like and then steps in to
wear like the sock like there's a
there's a brutal there's a overhang or
all the fluid that's being kept up from
from the socks mostly Gatorade they did
it to my dad when he had a congestive
heart failure they had a the doctor's
like you're fine just game compression
sucks
[ __ ] that could be it
yeah damn
I mean don't you go to the doctor though
I do
usually just Chit Chat
see anything good for breakfast yeah
um that's what I was worried my knee was
for a little bit
what that because my ankle does swell
it's a brain tumor in my knee
golly Skippy do you know anybody that's
ever had this I get calls like that
trying to solve problems scoliosis uh no
because my ankle
um was was a little was a little swelled
up swelled up swelled a little swole
and the knee was hurting and I was
worried that it was going up but I was
I've been checked for Lymphedema and
they said it's not my heart and all that
stuff because when that started
happening I had it all checked out
just just fatty McMuffins
how you doing we have a check but how do
you feel you're doing with the weight
loss challenge that's currently
happening not great I'll be honest with
you just this past week I've been
injured sure and there was a lot of food
around where I was you know well wishers
and whatnot what are you gonna do I
can't find a party Trey I'll try
get them in a headlock they got those
Zips down there too yeah hey you ever
have a zap I don't know what that is uh
it's like um
like a zeppole no it's a sandwich it's
like a it's like an Italian hoagie I
call them Zep stuff it's one place makes
them that down down down the street
called Eve's Philly shout out to him
thick piece of raw onion
heartburn sometimes the easiest 500
beans I've ever made Daddio ship it yeah
you don't think I'm filing for
bankruptcy before I step on it chapter
11
and 13. and I'll take a number four
please
teach after 11 super size what's chapter
13. ah there's one that means you don't
have money and then the other one means
is uh kind of like a business tool to
like
chapter 11 is that yeah I guess chapter
is what to get to get out of any
business pinch Toby look that up I think
it's
no I think file Chapter 11 is bad
chapter 13 is the one that's like rich
people use to like
reorganize wealth to determine how
they're going to pay you or something
like that that's Luke by the way I know
chapter 13 is the bankruptcy for
business yeah yeah but 11 for
reorganization oh 11's reorganization
chapter 13 is like I have no money
exactly are you wearing a t-shirt no
you're that you're you're that open yeah
damn how many but dude you got how many
he's got two buttons you have more
unbuttoned than buttoned and you got
crazy chest hair dude what you got Luke
is in here flexing on us you think he
just slept with a married woman
about to redo your vows watch out
because they keep coming back they keep
sending me pictures all the [ __ ] of
the cash of meat they get Let's Go Gang
do yourself favorites the fall what does
the fall mean turkey gobble gobble
[ __ ] that's right and let me tell you
something go to the grocery store do
yourself a favor try to find a
free-range antibiotic free turkey down
there it's trash it's probably from
[ __ ] three years ago yeah no kidding
that's from like Canadian Thanksgiving
1986. do yourself a favor get one
delivered from butcher box and the other
stuff they got there's unbelievable too
free range wild caught grass-fed
grass-fed it's top quality merchandise
here throw right in the freezer you're
ready to go hey well you gotta probably
go somewhere pick this up no bozos get
what you want delivered right to your
doorstep free shipping in the
continental U.S no surprise fees shows
from a variety of box options from
curated to customize change your plan
whenever you want enjoy the range of
high quality cuts that are hard to come
by at the grocery store at amazing value
exclusive member deals so you can save
big on your favorite Cuts like we've
said it a million times I got I got I
got [ __ ] bacon and ground beef coming
out my ears uh we love it big fans over
there at the Ryan household I know the
foleys love it yeah we do the main
course for Thanksgiving Thanksgiving
dinner can sometimes be a main course of
stress not anymore butcher boxes
offering our listeners free turkey what
with their first order sign up at
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get one 10 to 14
pound free turkey in Universe [ __ ] and
you can put your buck call me what are
you doing how much does that save you on
Thanksgiving that's the whole meal right
there I don't know anybody can afford
green bean casserole get a free turkey
that's crazy that's butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to claim this deal do
it yeah can't be this is all about
ladder ladder yes sir gang don't put
things off that are important to you we
all do it DMV this that the other thing
one thing you don't want to put off
getting yourself some term life
insurance and you can do that over at
ladder no doctors no needles up to three
million dollars in coverage do yourself
a favor get ladder today do not wait
yeah don't let your family you know hold
the bag Jam them up one last screw job
from the old Bozo of the family like me
don't do it gang I was uh take care of
it I got my ladder policy it's one of
those things that you think the
paperwork all to this to that it doesn't
you there's no needles no doctors no
paperwork 100 digital ladders customers
rate them a four point out of five stars
on trustpilot and they made Forbes best
life insurance list 2021 that's come on
all you need is a few minutes of phone a
laptop to apply a lot of smart
algorithms working real time so you
choose and find out if you're instantly
approved no hidden fees cancel any time
get a full refund if you change your
mind in the first 30 days so here's the
turkey baby go to ladderlife.com garbage
today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com
back to the show
oh Jesus all right
um
talking of this this one's from Ed and
this was a big debate of the making the
whole uh uh slab of bacon or not slab of
bacon that was quite controversial
uh-huh a lot of people on my side on
that a lot of people weren't I would
some people weren't
a lot of people cut it in half cut the
bacon in half
and people ate it raw I think more
people were on my side on that I don't
think so
how many did you get messages and well
wishes and whatnot I would like to see
the size of the gentleman and or ladies
messaging you now
too bad blind survey I don't know what
to do
yeah you're all both your blind to
diabetes
um all right this one is from and I get
anxious a bit while flying so my wife
makes a bunch of bacon and puts it in a
Ziploc for me to munch and calm me down
we call it pocket bacon
that's what I have to do to you let's
see golden retriever
that's begging strips right there
That's crazy dude bacon calming you down
it's like a Five Hour Energy that's a
different kind of fat
he might not thinking on a plane I'm
just regardless
that's a fat Behavior I wish bacon calm
me down
nice glass of bacon before I go to sleep
you never did that I would assume what
the warm milk before you go to bed no
that was like what you did in the
depression to me I thought that was
really horrible stuff Luke you ever get
involved in that
my Dad tried a couple times but like it
I mean congeals kind of at the top you
put in the microwave or something it's
kind of nah never worn milk
me either no it's Coco
oh every night no
huh some nights we'd have a cocoa before
we went to bed
yeah we would do tea sometimes as a kid
tea yeah my mom my mom would drink it so
I would like oh whatever yeah who was a
cup it's like having a cup of coffee
before you go to bed no black tea yeah
that's good caffeine is a dumbass it's
not a cup of coffee I think it has more
cat I think there's more caffeine in
black tea than there is in coffee I
don't know he's been he's been pulling
out a lot of [ __ ] facts and he ends
up being right new Toby what do you got
God
black tea is caffeinated but you just
would use a non-caffeinated tea yeah
there you go maybe I was drinking
hit the search button get your opinion
on this he's not heaven do you think
these dirt balls that the caffeinated do
you think Denise was drinking
caffeinated tea on a weeknight probably
come down from the wine
get her head on straight
black tea and coffee are similar damn
there you go you were wrong you said
more so I win Kippy wins put it in the
win column fair enough
black tea has less caffeine yeah less
huh
I'd like to see you after the show
Kobe always makes me look
none of my facts are ever right he hits
the buttons a little bit and it says I'm
right
um he's a team player Luke you don't
sign these checks very true he knows who
that is
and if you get one from me it's going to
be post-dated for a while
it's gonna be in another person's name
too
like just just make it out the cash from
your dad's checkbook
did that do like a big T is that what it
is
can you do your dad's autograph
signature he's like famous
his dad Shannon sharp uh-huh no I mean
like that I mean who's checking like a
permission slip in high school maybe so
I don't know if I ever told you can you
do it dude it's like comical like
comical how bad my father's is like
horrible uh-huh looks like a second
grader doing curse I'm not even joking
to the point where every time
I would get called in by new teachers
being like this is
why didn't you have your father sign
this because like if I did that on a
test and he actually said I had to sign
it and I would be like do you think I'm
[ __ ] stupid enough to hand in this
I'm like this is I have tea before bed
late I'm like this is so bad of you
would catch me in a heartbeat it's that
bad but we used to me and my brother
used to use that to our advantage
because once he got known that he had a
really bad one
it was just easy to do and they go oh
yeah Mr Ryan's is horrible later plus he
he played ball he signed a lot of stuff
yeah he didn't [ __ ] didn't he didn't
give a [ __ ] I mean he did that'd be but
he'd be like you know you got to get
this up whereas my mom would be like we
gotta sit down I could be yelling my
brother would be like don't let me
[ __ ] have to talk to you about this
again I go you got a [ __ ] as I'm
hopping out the car hey he's signing all
he's signing on the [ __ ] center
console with a fresh 20 and a BB gun
[ __ ] later I'll see you next weekend
pops I'm out
make sure you stock up on the [ __ ]
Wawa iced tea will you I like those
pretzel goldfish
ah yeah my mom would freak out too my
dad they would talk to you like they
worked for you what they would talk to
you like they were hey you know I just
want to see a little more hustle I'll
give you a little hustle and hear about
your parents yeah but my parents
signatures
Denise had a solid one that was a
Catholic School [ __ ] hit you with the
rulers if it wasn't good I don't know if
my parents thought she was left-handed
that's hard to do [ __ ] goes off on a
[ __ ] yeah dog leg left Midway through
the name I don't know if my parents were
trained by the CIA but their signatures
were impossible really I can duplicate
yeah impossible
because they cared back in the day I
mean we signed stuff I signed Lisa all
that it's just [ __ ] whatever you ever
signed into one of those electric pads
[ __ ]
that like you have to sign stuff now
like due to covid everything you know
like hey sign on uh Adobe or whatever I
just like but yeah
later can you write in cursive new guy
Luke
it would take me a few minutes to
relearn it really what about you
probably yeah I mean a big cursive guy
we only used it you know we learned it
in second I think to Third and then that
was we were we I used it all the way
through
High School everything had to be in
cursive
wow we weren't turning anything
handwritten at that point really
damn
back 10 years that was it
that's one compute I mean not your
computer's hit in the 90s that's when I
was in
you know I was eight I mean we had
computer class in second third grade
shout out to Oregon Trail shout out to
[ __ ] number muncher [ __ ] hated
Oregon Trail
it was great dude whack I didn't get it
yeah I mean but you're coming from like
you were probably older so you're like
this is the other kids you know finger
Papa cheerleader all right I ain't
speaking my language just spotters dork
um but yeah I mean I was like four I'm
like or whatever seven six I'm like this
is sweet I'd be weird to like it if he
could drive a car kids were we a
computer didn't come into our home until
I was in college and I took it with me
it was
um
it wasn't a Dell Gateway an Epson it was
an Epson epic aren't they salt take a
bath with it cool down it was an Epson
and it had nine floppy disks that you
had to put in to type something up I had
a printer though
I have I have one now I don't sound like
a cat getting murdered
everything's real Jiffy till they go to
print out the receipt but other kids I
think were more uh computer
knowledgeable than me I have literally
every single person on the planet is
more computer knowledgeable than you
true now just even now true true
um but I even own a computer do you
now I don't know holy [ __ ] I don't want
a computer
the bird does I got a laptop and [ __ ]
work stuff computers on a [ __ ] I'd use
my phone
using my phone it's easier I'll rub your
friend you on huh yeah though hold it in
this hand formula on the other all right
getting busy I'm in and out in two
seconds too oh that's good
what are you doing on the cow I'm never
sitting on your couch
in the closet like a gentleman Hey
listen I'm Bros I know what a Cathedrals
apparently can't I'll get our kicks off
walking down the street
you guys gotta put a little work this
one I don't even get this is from uh uh
SCI first time long time is it garbage
or lighted joint in the microwave
hmm I heard like we I remember people
used to put blunts in there for like a
second or two just to try them out try
them out like if you licked it too much
instead of doing the lighter pop it in
the microwave for three seconds or
whatever I remember that but how do you
light a jump wait how do you how does it
light on the end I don't think that
works
maybe that's what new guy Luke see if
you can light a joint in the uh
in the microwave that's crazy that
doesn't make sense what if it lit in the
middle you know what I mean that would
suck dude there is my There Goes My
dubage
now they probably mean to dry it out
I put a pair of sneakers in there
to mold your feet at baked potato
[Music]
that's pretty good
um
what do you got there seems like a fire
hazard yeah at the very best yeah that's
no good he must have he must have meant
to dry the joint
I don't know this guy's Bonkers clearly
all hopped up on [ __ ] reefer it's a
little weird okay you never smoked
bananas right
people smoked banana peels back in the
day banana peels yeah something like
that we would smoke cinnamon sticks it's
coming back on Tick Tock and stuff
people are like shaving off the banana
peeled for blunt wraps okay now this was
you smoked a banana peel and it got you
a little high or something
I thought I remember we didn't [ __ ] with
it we smoked uh
cinnamon sticks you know like the the
become like rolled yeah you could
[ __ ] light it I'm like [ __ ] smoke
it and that was like before we got our
hands on Bernie's remember 1.2 who
smoked the stuff called tube grass we
were [ __ ] idiot we just wanted to
smoke I was just young dude nine Jesus
and it was just like a weed like it was
like a like a piece of hay kind of and
you broke it and we get a lighter and
just like sit in the woods in a tree
fort and just [ __ ] it would you inhale
it yeah would you inhale the cinnamon
stick yeah would it [ __ ] you up a little
bit I don't know it was nine huh we used
to [ __ ] with um
crack now it's before crack would get it
down at Felton Street uh uh the
formaldehyde e now yeah formaldehyde wet
wet what's wet dude wet is way different
than cinnamon sticks it was on cinnamon
sticks or for children and desserts
the [ __ ] wet is for [ __ ] drug
addicts and dead people nice cappuccino
yeah what the whole [ __ ] it was tea
leaves or something soaked in
formaldehyde or yeah wet okay
yeah yeah that's in Training Day when he
looks at him he's like
it was weird because he looks hey he
looks at him because I didn't know you
get wet wart
but I don't think it was weed there was
weed in that dipped in from aldehyde I
think but this was like tea leaves and
formaldehyde
much better for you
it's organic at least
I just wonder if there's any caffeine in
those tea leaves it was Bigelow yeah oh
Jesus man now I never cinnamon
yeah I was [ __ ] so stupid I never put
drugs in the microwave
put weed in the freezer
with a little you know we used to do it
was real nice if you got a nice bag of
kind bud okay that's we called it back
into how old you are yeah kind bud
dank was big
was it dank swag swiggits that's what
that's what we started with it started
off dank
am I guess in my head at the time was KB
dank mids
anyways you got a nice bag of kind bud
nice eighth you wanted to keep it fresh
you'd put in a little tupperware
container with a little orange orange
peel or something yeah that didn't work
ah that sucked [ __ ] you looked real
close nothing's [ __ ] worse than like
14 year old Stoner science you know what
I mean
I hear the seeds are good put a Skittle
in there the [ __ ] bill took a steep
of a seed home he's growing it in his
attic yeah okay Steve
you don't even know how to germinate
them
you gotta put in the microwave dumbass I
don't matter with you
uh
um all right let's see here I still want
to throw Mario Ripper we're having a
good time uh this one's from AC Dune uh
do you own any household appliances that
require pliers or a screwdriver to turn
it on properly
at the moment
well
we have an issue with the turret where
we have to keep a screwdriver handy
right now because they [ __ ] with the
water pressure in the building we had an
incident which I might have discussed on
the pod
the water going everywhere just it
wouldn't just shut off the a backless uh
toilet
yeah and it has a flushometer on it
there's a valve yeah yeah and it was
just going
I told you this never told us this and
they were supposed to check everyone and
they didn't every apartment to make sure
that the valves were in the right spot
but now
um yeah I remember TVs we had to have
the pliers this has gone way back yeah
going way back because the button was
gone I don't remember anything specific
we always had like our fridge for a long
time
at the piece's house you'd have to I
mean too long
eight ten years maybe wouldn't close
right you had to like lift it and push
it in and drop it down oh yeah
a decade I think a proper decade that's
what made it yours though yeah I made it
special you had to tell people hey yeah
I'll get it just Lee I'll get there you
gotta lift you gotta put a hitch unit
you know what I mean my phone they would
let a few we had so many instructions
sure things in our house to to older
people pull it out click it back in
yeah of course you just get used to it
switch out the roll the batteries or
something I had that with my phone
because I just got a new phone but the
phone I had before it it was like slowly
dying the left wouldn't work the button
the eye wouldn't work
um if I wanted to type numbers I had to
turn it to the side you just get used to
doing that stuff and just roll with it
sure
um the only thing my my mother didn't
tolerate
was and I used to freak me out when I
would go to like a friend's house and
they would have this if there was no
light bulb in the refrigerator oh no
that's like a power outage no effect I
know but I'm saying it feels like you're
in a power outage it feels like
everything's getting warmer real quick I
wouldn't [ __ ] with anything unless there
was a light in there everything seems
bad right away and if if you had a buddy
who's
parents refrigerator's light was out
it's a good chance the whole fridge
smelled like coleslaw like a weird way I
feel like everything was wet too like it
was everything was like
switching uh now temperature
temperatures you know what's nice is the
other light watch your meatloaf cooking
mm-hmm
gentleman we get this this is one of the
common questions we've mentioned before
uh it's probably like weekly we get it
but uh uh turning the stove on to heat
the house
yeah in the morning she was [ __ ]
making it you know making you a [ __ ]
fried egg Sammy with the oven open and
she's in a [ __ ] ski jacket like she's
about to go on a [ __ ] ski lift this
one
also I forget how big the show is now
this is quite a Big Show and I have a
lot of family and friends that listen
shout out to the bozos and the homies we
love you yeah but the [ __ ] chicken we
gotta teach we gotta have a chicken
sandwich code for the live for the for
the public apps because all this shit's
getting back to [ __ ] Denise
I catch a rash in his [ __ ] every time I
see it I heard you talking about you're
telling a story about how I [ __ ] it yeah
yeah I got that too what was she
bitching about the other day Patty was
coming at me about something you told
them this you told them Terry
oh I had a good time with her uh the
other day we were talking about
something and I said something crazy
I said something like I said not to do
something because it would lead to this
this and this all right
um and normally somebody would have been
like that but shut up what are you
talking about and we were driving and
she's like oh yeah that's pretty good oh
God you too she knew it oh man you're
easy yeah Mama cray-cray you two are you
two together are
we wacky tobacco like Danny you guys are
getting wet together [ __ ] smoking
Sherm been playing this all weekend
ripping heaters
um
but [ __ ] what there was something oh
for the longest time in the Montego
shout out to him
um I used to have to it would get stuck
in park do you remember this yeah if we
get stuck in part oh remember the night
that might have been that was the trip
the impetus of are you garbage remember
we were driving back from Altoona
Altoona and we were that was when I was
making funny for drinking milk at dinner
remember we laughed and then we laughed
and we laughed and we stopped at that
wacky [ __ ] gas station
oh it's a real sketchy yeah and the guy
came out from the back remember that was
like four in the morning maybe in the
middle of [ __ ] Pennsylvania yeah and
we thought they were getting robbed or
something like that I didn't know what
no we thought they were gonna come after
us so you were like [ __ ] let's go oh
yeah and then they were like oh the
bathroom's around back and he was like
it was like that scene in casino with
[ __ ] dinero like yeah keep going and
I'm like I got it for my [ __ ] Spidey
senses went up and I was like no way I
ran back in the car then they think you
sure I'll pee on myself they came out to
be like oh remember they started it was
like Jeepers Creepers or whatever they
came out of the front to be like no
you're doing it like where are you going
and I couldn't get the montigo was stuck
in park one of them was a woman I
remember yeah there was a woman and a
guy I think two women and a guy and you
were like uh you were like [ __ ] go
man go and they were walking closer to
the car and dude there's not a soul
inside like there's probably not a
person for 500 miles they would have to
blow the propane tank to kill him yeah
uh-huh that's how we would have done it
like the end of Tremors yeah that's what
I want to see crazy no but you're good I
remember you're like [ __ ] go dude it
was one of those things where you're
like and I'm like shut the [ __ ] up like
I'm like relax I need to concentrate
because like you had to feel the Clicks
in it to get it you know what I mean
like you had to really it's like a
[ __ ] safe it was and you were
screaming I remember being like shut the
[ __ ] up man I gotta get like just shut
up and let me do this
did we peel the [ __ ] out of there you
got a stethoscope on the Wheel
hey man you're like they made the call
the cops the fuzz are coming
they sent the signal the call went out
the call went out but we gotta wrap her
up gang we love you to death we love you
so much for tuning in come see a live
show Gang couple opportunities Charlotte
uh Atlanta guys we have two shows in
Atlanta playing the red red clay Comedy
Festival Atlanta get those [ __ ]
tickets those are gonna be a good
[ __ ] time yeah you can just get
tickets
um yeah you don't have to buy passes to
the uh
uh Festival you can just buy individual
tickets unless you want to or you want
to of course yeah I'm just letting you
know you have multiple options there
um and then there's another show in
Rhode Island on sale right now and then
they're showing Boston those shows will
most likely sell out as well so if
you're digging around kicking rocks get
those [ __ ] Dickies make a move gang
we love you also hold on we have merch
available I have new guy Luke here uh
merch available and also go follow the
clip channel the ru garbage there you go
uh clip shadow new guy Luke is in charge
of that those numbers are creeping uh we
post you know anything from shorts you
know under a minute uh 10 minute chunks
of uh some of the best Heavy Hitters and
highlights most chest hair on YouTube
check it out peace